[Música]
y en directo a vamos a Brasil en el
estado de Río Grande de norche que ha
experimentado una serie de ataques
violentos en los últimos días y en los
que edificios públicos han sido atacados
y vehículos han sido incendiados Qué es
lo que está pasando allí los detalles
nos los entregaba previamente desde Río
de Janeiro nuestra corresponsal Valeria
saconi
sería la reacción de una facción de
narcotraficantes llamada sindicado del
crimen a una serie de detenciones y
también a la prevención de armas y
drogas en el estado de Río Grande
donoorchi en el norte de Brasil han sido
dos noches de terror en Qué edificios
públicos han sido atacados con armas de
fuego también han sido incendiados
autobuses hay al menos dos heridos y la
policía investigación comerciante muerto
podría estar relacionado con esos
ataques en algunas ciudades como natal
la capital de ese estado homóforo se han
tenido que suspender servicios básicos
como el transporte público los
ambulatorios las escuelas finalmente el
presidente del país se lo hice en la
célula da Silva ha enviado fuerzas
especiales federales Para apoyar a la
policía local y además la policía ha
abatido al supuesto cabecilla de esta
que sería en tesis el responsable de
haber organizado esta ola violenta de
ataques
Valeria también nos comentó Cuáles se
supone que son los pedidos de quienes
estarían detrás de estos hechos
violentos
son varias las reivindicaciones de esta
facción criminal que controla las
principales cárceles de todo el estado
de Río Grande del Norte La principal es
que vuelvan las visitas íntimas de las
esposas que fueron suspendidas después
de un motín que causó al menos 30
muertos también exigen que se permita la
entrada de televisores a las cárceles y
que vuelvan las bombillas a las celdas
actualmente solo hay luz en los pasillos
para evitar que los presos puedan
recargar los celulares clandestinos que
entran a las instalaciones carcelarias
hay que recordar que Brasil tiene la
tercera mayor población carcelaria del
mundo y que las protestas contra las
malas condiciones de los presos son
recurrentes la más famosa y la más
importante hace más de 30 años en la
cárcel de carandirú en San Pablo Pero
llama la atención que en el estado de
Río Grande donarchy desde 2016 ya ha
habido cuatro grandes olas de ataques
lideradas por narcotra que de esta forma
intentan hacer presiones sobre las
autoridades para conseguir una mejora de
las condiciones de los presos y que
acepten sus reivindicaciones